you said there's a lot of kind of
little pieces of evidence for this thing
that's planet nine
if we were to try to collect more
evidence
or be certain like a paper that says
like you drop it clear we're done
what what is that required does that
require us sending probes out
or do you think we can do it from
telescopes here on earth what are the
different ideas for conclusive evidence
for planet nine
the moment planet nine gets imaged from
a telescope on earth it's done i mean
it's just there
can you clarify because you mentioned
that before from an
image would you be able to tell yes so
from an image
the moment you see something something
that is reflecting
sunlight back at you and
you know that it's hundreds of
times as far away from the sun as as is
the earth
you're done so you're thinking so
basically if you have a really far away
thing that's
big yeah you know five times the size of
earth
that means uh that
that is planet could there be multiple
objects like that i guess
in principle yeah i mean there's no
there's no law of physics that
uh that doesn't allow you to have
multiple there's also no evidence
at present for there being multiple i
wonder if it's possible so it's like
just like we're finding exoplanets
whether given the size of the ore cloud
there's basically
it's rare and rare but they're sprinkled
planet 9
10 11 12 like these yeah
some got 13. yeah it goes after that
yeah i can just keep counting
so like just something about the dynamic
system
like it becomes lower and lower
probability event but they gather up
like they become they become larger and
larger maybe
something like that and i wonder i
wonder if like discovering planet nine
will just like be almost like a
springboard it's like well what's
what's beyond that it's entirely
plausible the oort cloud itself
probably holds about five earth masses
or seven earth masses of material
um right so it's not it's not nothing
and the it all ultimately
comes down to
at what point will the observational
surveys
sample enough of the solar system to uh
kind of
reveal interesting things
there's a great analogy here with
neptune and the story of how neptune was
discovered
neptune was not discovered by looking at
the sky
right it was discovered by uh it was
certain mathematically
right so yeah the orbit of
uranus when uranus was found um
this was 1781 it's
the kind of tracking uh both the
tracking of
the orbit of uranus as well as the
reconstruction of
the orbit of uranus immediately revealed
that
it was not following the orbit that it
was supposed to
right the the predicted orbit deviated
away from where it actually was
so uh in the mid 1800s
right a french mathematician by the name
of orban le verrier
did a beautifully sophisticated
calculation which said
if this is due to gravity of a
more distant planet then that planet is
there
okay and then they found it but the
point is the
understanding of where to look for
neptune came entirely out of celestial
mechanics
the case with planet nine is a little
bit different
because what we can do i think
relatively well is predict the orbit and
mass of planet nine we cannot tell you
where it is on its orbit the reason is
we haven't seen
the kuiper belt objects complete in
orbit
their own orbit even once because it
takes 4 000 years
but you know i plan to live on as an ai
being uh and you know i'll i'll be
tracking those
uh those orbits as solid takes four or
five thousand years i mean
it doesn't have to be ai it could be
longevity there's a lot of really
exciting genetic engineering research
so you'll just be a brain waiting for
the
for the your brain waiting for the orbit
to complete for the basic kuiper belt
objects
that's that's right that's like kind of
the worst
reason to want to live a long time right
just like can the brain like smoke a
cigarette
can you just like light one up while
you're waiting or
you